il y en a certains que les mesures
sanitaires néo frais par arnaud baptiste
et ingrid ont ouvert les portes de leur
restaurant il y a trois semaines à tour
pourtant l'espoir est là et il espère
pouvoir accueillir leurs clients très
bientôt
alors comment cela se passe en pleine
pandémie explications avec lucas chopin
c'est un pari risqué
le restaurant chez mady a ouvert ses
portes au début du mois envers et contre
tout pourtant ses débuts sont
encourageants comme le confirme arnaud
son co-gérant on s'en sort oui on peut
assumer notre loyer on peut assumer le
salaire de notre salarié et les matières
premières on a eu des gens qui nous ont
dit bon faudrait peut-être réfléchir là
maintenant et non on était trois ans et
dans le projet on en avait trop envie on
l'avait trop imaginer pour faire marche
arrière les locaux ont été refaits à
neuf et leur localisation place
plumereau leur garantit une place de
choix dans la ville baptiste fouchard a
bon espoir que la carte et l'ambiance
permettent d'occuper très prochainement
les 75 places du restaurant c'est une
cuisine de bistrot on va dire simple
avec des produits locaux possibles
tout est fait maison de a à z on a
beaucoup beaucoup d'espoir
on est très content déjà d'avoir ouvert
et de revoir du monde c'est très
important
on aime l'esprit de partage de
convivialité de fait on rigole on parle
fort on voit là on s'amuse et c'est
vraiment ce qu'on veut donner aux gens
schéma 10 propose ses plats en livraison
ou click and collect il fera également
office de bar et de maisons à tapas à la
française
dès que les mesures sanitaires le
permettront